♪♪ INTRO ♪♪
A little over three years ago, I saw a video
on YouTube of a cell dying and I loved it
so much that I reached out to the
person who posted that video.
His name was James, and in that email,
I wrote the following:
“I have always wanted to do a microscopy
show, we've just lacked the expertise.
You have something pretty special on your
hands, an obvious passion, talent,
and the right equipment.
I'm interested in possibly partnering with
you on a channel. I'm thinking of
something that has a real chill look and feel.
Something that celebrates
the beauty of that world, gives people
a chance to relax while also learning.”
James agreed.
It is unusual for an idea to go from inception
to execution with so little modification.
That first pitch is very much what this channel
continues to be today.
Aside from the original idea for the name
of the channel which was…
The Germ House.
Through the years, there have been some very
exciting developments.
James has been able to upgrade his microscope
multiple times.
We’ve been able to share marine life as
well as fresh water.
We’ve captured some truly exceptional moments
and even, we think, discovered entirely new species.
But also, how I have thought about microscopy
has changed.
Before I found James’ footage, I wanted
to make microscopy content but I thought I couldn't.
There were so many microscopes, and so
many different words I didn’t know.
I honestly didn't even know
what a ciliate was!
As I watched more and more footage, and narrated
more and more episodes, I started to understand
that this isn’t something that’s just
for experts.
Obviously, I will never be as accomplished
as James.
But after getting my own Microcosmos Microscope
as part of our Kickstarter, I found that this
was an extremely fulfilling and also fairly
accessible hobby.
Spending time in my neighborhood understanding
my local microcosmos has been very exciting.
The changing ecology of the seasons, my first
tardigrade sighting, and just the variety
of life at different depths of water and sediment.
The Microcosmos Microscope changed my whole
outlook on this channel.
It’s not just a project that tells people
about their world, we hope it is an
invitation into that world.
There are so many more people with telescopes
than microscopes, but, no offense to all of
the backyard astronomers out there, there
is so much more to see
looking down than looking up.
And we want to help more people start their
own journeys, so they can explore the unseen
world that surrounds them.
So that’s why we launched the Microcosmos
Microscope Kickstarter in early 2021, and
we made sure to offer a high quality introductory
microscope, with a cell-phone adapter, so
the everybody could document their own journeys.
And the people who supported that kickstarter
have enabled the next step we are taking today
the launch of Microcosmos.store.
This new store exists to welcome folks on
their own journeys.
Right now, we’ve got a fairly limited number
of Microcosmos Microscopes available, but
we will be restocking them later this year,
so get them while they're hot.
We’ll also be increasing the number
of microscopy tools and accessories we offer.
Right now, along with the microscope, you can
get things like Rheinberg filters, oblique
illumination filters, slides and coverslips,
our microscopy field guide, and a Microcosmos
microfiber cleaning cloth.
We even have a series of instructional videos
explaining how to get started with both the
equipment and sampling your local microcosmos.
Also, of course, we’ve got some cool stuff
that you can get to represent your appreciation
for the microcosmos.
You can download our soundtrack to listen
to while you search your slides, or cozy up
in our new Lacrymaria socks.
We’ve also got a glow-in-the-dark tardigrade
pin, a very cool and clever sweatshirt, and
this new hydra t-shirt is just fantastic.
And finally, possibly my favorite thing is
this poster, with art by one of James’ mentors
that will help you identify the microbes you
find in your samples.
It has over 100 species on it and it also
just looks really really cool.
In case it’s not clear to you, we really
have been going on a journey together.
And I’m not just saying words when I say
thank you for coming on it with us.
I am so grateful to have had this richness
added to my life.
A new and deep appreciation for something
that was, just a few short years ago, the
unseen world that surrounds me.
Now before we go, we’d also like to thank each
and every one of our Patreon patrons.
Without whom this channel and this store
could not exist and we are so so grateful
for all of you who have decided to sign up
over at patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you’d like to see more from our Master
of Microscopes James Weiss, check him
out at Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you’d like to see more from us, there’s
probably a subscribe button somewhere nearby.